fueron 1.200 personas las que se
refugiaron del genocidio de ruanda de
1994 en el emblemático hotel de 1000
colin en kigali sugerente paul
rusesabagina fue aclamado como un héroe
en todo el mundo ahora es uno de los
principales críticos del gobierno de
paul kagamé pasa era recepcionista en el
hotel en 1994 y asegura que la
reputación de roses a vagina es
exagerada rusia estaba llena de sets doc
deshacerse un lodo de efectivo y llenos
y rusesabagina usaba víctimas del
genocidio para hacer negocio les robaba
todo su dinero
eso no me pase eso de hacer que el
míster que pasaba su tiempo de fiesta
con los soldados que estaban matando los
tutsis fuera del hotel y luego llegaban
al hotel para celebrar 15 ene efe de la
fed los hora de excluir a los tels
el niega estas acusaciones fuera de
ruanda muchos supervivientes del
genocidio todavía le agradecen por
salvarles la vida pero el gobierno la
acusa de traición abriendo una guerra de
narrativas
phillips no te here is the hero made in
hollywood supervivientes del genocidio
no lo ven como un héroe es un héroe
hecho en hollywood los traicionó vendió
su historia para hacer dinero
groups his fund y fundó y financió
grupos terroristas y estos grupos
terroristas han atacado a ruanda se la
está actuando rusesabagina acusa a
kagamé de crímenes de guerra y se ha
convertido en un enemigo del estado
mientras que el gobierno lo acusa de
terrorismo
lo arrestaron en agosto cuando regresaba
desde dubai
usó la plataforma de hotel ruanda para
exponer violaciones de derechos humanos
que el gobierno de paul kagamé todavía
comete contra la población
son para lo que hindú kill a un lado
live así que fue secuestrado y llevado a
ruanda por la fuerza violando la ley
internacional o la violación del
levantón nacional el parlamento europeo
firmó una moción para pedir una
investigación internacional sobre estas
confusas circunstancias y para que tenga
un juicio justo